this madness madness this is onion trade
that should adorn herself
haha that onion kid poof you know the
man I saw that kid one of those happen
say is like oh yeah I'm like who's onion
why does he look like the top of an ice
cream cone and why yeah and then it's
like we learned a little bit more I
guess icing and running over all of the
ketchup packets and crashing that moped
this is definitely the actions of a
serial killer I don't uh I get the antes
ago you just miss your father right not
is it okay you can have a Pam likes no
nose said who else is going on I don't
trust that he does ice yeah and it's
like nobody just like once this scepter
has everything go dark II just let's
have creepy little smile and then
duplicates all this stuff and then like
tries to kill people to keep it and it's
just like okay you don't like no this
something's up with this kid this yeah
it's got more to him and with with the
fire in the background it was like
something that a fucking Barton faint I
yeah I will show you the why for the bar
I I just didn't get this nd I'm just
like ever like well why would they be
okay with us why would I just be like
that little twerp belongs in jail or Jim
jail whatever they call cuz he misses
his father then that's what minder guy
means to me if they talk without words
it's just mulling around that he just
gets my back I need throws the the
hamburger he doesn't feel like he's one
of the Dark One's hang out in this and
like he he handles with the guy with the
briefcase to get his lunch or something
and it's a and why did he steal oh my
god maybe you shouldn't be so judgmental
like why did steal that toy like Stephen
was wrong about oh you took it cuz it's
a symbol of me my father
no just the first thing okay but it's
like he's still okay really we're
dumping on any in this much but we're
not gonna like bring up the fact that
fucking amethyst just hand Steven this
device of unholy terror no I'm more hung
up on what did you copy before oh yeah
everything we copies Detroit yeah not
just like okay listen
what did she copy this fucking show I'm
sure it's gonna be like also one day
your side we're gonna be like oh go
didn't you know that was like a loved
one or something she cops I don't know
it looks like all those other versions
of me are dead
yeah like what shit the oh the fucking
wolves anyway she had the fucking
prestige going off and somewhere in the
basement this um this episode just it
raises too many questions questions
which I do think should be answered
I think we're best cutting no I need to
know I need to know what the hell's
going on with all this anymore time
spent with onion is too scary now that I
kind of agree with Slayer even before
they gave in this episode I just saw the
kid I'm like I don't like the waist
design I don't like the way he's just
always kind of the background just I'm
like I don't get my gym ok serial killer
I don't I don't trust him now why do
they trust him at the end of this I mean
is awful little boy oh he is the bad
seed it's reminds you that kid from the
twilight zone that Simpsons Halloween
episode were like Bart took control
people like cuz he doesn't say much he
just like nonsan yeah no it's women
somewhere a head explodes yeah it's a
now watch
now watch after we're talking about how
like last episode like dogcopter so
waited oh hell people be like oh dog
catching I know it's scary so gonna be
like oh oh you guys are so mean to onion
wait next episode you defined that if I
go like yeah his mother's dead and his
father somehow turn into his mother but
then turned back his mother died at
Auschwitz
it's a grave or something you know fall
now we're gonna find he's down there
stop him and now II feel like you know
if they want us to like feel like oh
he's just a cute little lost boy or
something like that they did not explain
that very well like maybe something's
gonna happen to know that I have to say
open up like thing to knock over that
very low just gets us the cute little
island doesn't talk like you had it like
it's a background of fire all because of
guys damn guys so many guys I also have
to say the line about losing your
innocence
yeah do Alex Riley I want something
precious to me your innocence funny was
the lead-in
then I was like what the fuck because
he's like he walks in and his dad's like
well what the hell do you say you look
on I don't know I I was too focused on
any SLI but something about being he
said you know it's like you look wet and
sad is something wrong in your life I've
lost something your innocence I was like
whoa Wow ah I do think it was
interesting too when he sprayed him with
the hose like the water literally went
everywhere it's like almost up to like
the mountains it's like this there's a
hose battle and then but his dad was
just like literally just like then I'm
like bent
that just seems malicious um also if
he's always wearing shorts how's the
edits tank tub why does he have a some
of them plays he wears a shirt a long
pan
see I have a theory I hope for you go
for like when he made love to Rose if
that's how they procreate I have no idea
ah and like the way that happened know
when it happened it left us some sort of
mark on it now though cuz there's no way
he can just have that red mark on it
don't go there Rose was a beautiful
woman you shut up I didn't say there's
anything wrong with it I just said maybe
that's the mark they leave or something
I don't know cuz it's like like you said
he always wears shorts and everything
and I don't know um make it warm just
looking at whatever I see that sunburn
I'm like god I just feel like strength
II what else a Fantas know it's that was
so much fucking weird I had I had to
laugh cuz when amethyst was talking
about um what the hell did she say um I
was looking for amethyst oh she said I
was looking for Amma I found this while
looking for amethyst or not even for a
pearl I found this while looking for
pearls duh max but the way she said it
for a second I thought she said I found
this while looking for pearls dumbasses
yeah did you hear that too and they'll
know when you serve a piano Maya pity
her last um yeah what else can you say
about this episode he likes to run over
ketchup packets and blow up bikes
Street creepy kids well because they may
kill you someday
yeah especially if again duplicating
right it sounds like Marvin the Martian
thing this duplicating ray
um I use it to I don't know it obstructs
my view of Venus that's an answer for
everything yeah and how buns get between
it Outlook wiki um but yeah just a weird
kind of disturbing episode just every
because we don't get all these so many
questions are raised and we don't get
answers they'll probably be answer later
but sighs cold dead soulless stare I
just yeah I don't like that kid I don't
like onion but maybe they'll give them
an you know something like Randall and
as of now we ran off with Ranger guy
just what's he gonna do with it yeah I
just I don't trust that little thing I
don't know the basic battle like in the
final episode it's gonna be between
light the crystal gems let's let's go
and stole a security system just in case
onion yeah I dress that's good here just
someone that watched on DNA is like you
know what I want to be onion and just
like wears it in a woman suit or
something like that would you fuck me
I'd fuck me would you trade onions i
trade my onion oh oh we got to trade for
Dave girl okay we got stop